okay so wakanda forever's original
script it's something I think it's
impossible not to wonder about in the
wake of the movie's release due to
Chadwick boseman's death the production
was massively changed with Ryan coogler
having to deal with the monumentous task
of rewriting the entire thing from the
ground up because of the actor's passing
however due to interviews and the Black
Panther will come to Forever podcast we
now have a fair idea of what was going
to be in it in this video we're going to
be going through everything we know was
in the original plan and also our
general thoughts about it there may be
some spoilers here in regards to the
final film so if you haven't had a
chance to check it out then please check
out now if you enjoyed the video we'd
love you 3000 if you hit the thumbs up
button and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day without
the way I'm your host Paul now let's get
into our original wakanda forever script
breakdown
her shadwick's death looms largely over
the film with cougars stating that he
and the cast put their loving grief into
every aspect of the movie The Weekly
Planet recently touched upon what the
director experienced when finishing the
first draft and we now know from the
official black panther podcast that
cougar actually sent this off to
Chadwick when discussing the script he
said I had just finished it my last
conversation with him was calling him
and asking if he wanted to read it
before I got notes from the studio that
was the last time we spoke and he passed
maybe a couple of weeks after I finished
coogler has since gone on to say that
though he never suspected Chadwick had
cancer at the time in retrospect he
could tell something was off during the
filming of the first movie he stated
that shadwick would seem tired from time
to time and that he'd need to take
breaks more often than usual in some
days we now know what Chadwick was
battling with and looking at his
performance it's actually incredible
that he got through it all with the pain
that he was in now when discussing their
last conversation coogler said he was
tired I could tell he was tired I'd been
trying to get hold of him for a few days
I could tell something was up but he was
joking and laughing talking about how he
was planning a wedding in South Carolina
talking about the people he was going to
invite and then he said he didn't want
to read it because he didn't want to get
in the way of whatever notes the studio
might have so he was like it's better if
I read it later but I found out later
that he was too tired to read anything
it's devastating to find this out and
it's clear that he influenced how they
handled t'challa's passing due to him
fighting his disease in secret CBR
recently reported that Chadwick didn't
fact get the chance to read it though
and that Leticia ride her through the
grapevine that the actor had been making
fun of how long it was he'd been joking
that it was over 300 Pages which would
make it one of the longest MC movies
ever this carries over to the final
version 2 with a clocking in at 2 hours
and 41 minutes interestingly though we
now know that the original version also
dealt with the themes of grief 2. in an
interview with inverse coogler LED out
the entire plan and the first thing he
talked about was the grief that the
movie tackled with however this was
t'challa dealing with his own grief of
the snap and the time that was lost when
Thanos snapped away half of all life in
the universe t'challa was one of the
Unlucky ones that were taken and this
would have left the throne empty for
five years coogler said that the movie
was gonna address this directly and that
its tone would be similar to what we got
in the final release we're going over
this Ryan said the character was going
to be grieving the loss of time you know
coming back after being gone for five
years as a man with so much
responsibility to many coming back after
a forced five years away that's what the
film was tackling he was grieving time
he couldn't get back grief was a big
part of it coogler stated that Shiri was
snapped away too and that they would
both return with this feeling of loss
now personally I feel one of the big
flaws in the MCU at the moment is that
we haven't really dealt with what
happened in those five years there's
been minor moments like the Ronin plot
in the Disney plus Hawkeye show but
beyond that it's something we know very
little about it's meant to be a
completely depressing time too with
Haywood and one division saying they had
to do dark things in order to survive
this ended up making him work to bring
Vision back to life so that planet Earth
had its own protector Kugler said that
wakanda forever would tackle this idea
too and then element of the final film
was laced throughout this early draft in
that we watch his Fran's attempts to
steal vibranium from the wakandans at
one of their research Labs the original
script had elements of this as well were
the fact that t'challa was gone for five
years causing big issues because the
kingdom didn't have a black panther had
protected several government entities
had tried to intrude an attack in order
to gain the precious material for
themselves killmonger destroyed all of
the Sacred herbs and because of this
they couldn't pass the mantle onto
anyone else the nation had no protector
and this put even more guilt onto the
shoulders of t'challa he returned to
find wakandra in the midst of a cold war
with the UN desperate to gain vibranium
the film of course ended with t'challa
opening up wakanda to the world and he
would have to deal with the fact that
they had betrayed him though Michael B
Jordan's return Isn't mentioned in any
of the interviews I think this is
because of spoilers that it could bring
to people going to see the film however
I think that he would have appeared in
the film in some form or another he
wanted to take the fight of the world
and make wukon known through the use of
force t'challa on the other hand wanted
it to be peaceful and I can't help but
think seeing hashtag killmonger was
right might make him question his own
leadership abilities the Chala was very
much forced into being King by the
sudden death of his father and though he
beat him Baku for the throne his Reign
had been marked by a lot of turmoil we
of course had killmonger usurping him
and then Thanos attacking wakande so
it's a lot to deal with and him failing
to protect his Nation would be another
big thing that I think would have added
to the guilt the villain of the movie
was always gonna be no more with Kugler
stating that he was always the
antagonist black panther anymore have
fought several times in the comics
before but both Atlantis and wakanda are
going to war with each other in the
comics and Warren t'challa's rivalry was
first introduced in the 1970s but when
we look at the timeline of the Marvel
Universe they've fought long before that
the first battle happened during World
War II and over the decades they've had
an uneasy Alliance that's constantly
constantly broken there's been several
tense exchanges with him and pretty much
every time they talk there's a chance
things could kick off Black Panther and
Amor are some of the only Marvel
characters that are actually rulers and
it's not like when Iron Man attacks
somewhere because he isn't a leader of a
country they however are and therefore
Every Act is seen as something that can
destabilize the peace on the political
landscape interestingly sure you know
more fought each other during Civil War
2 which may have provided basis for the
final cut the tidal wave scene was there
too with this being a major attack that
no more launched because of this I'm
guessing that ramonda died in the
original version of the script without
starting a streak of Vengeance within
the king t'challa the final release ends
with Shiri realizing that vengeance is
consuming hair and this is a line that
calls back to t'challa saying it in
Civil War I think that a similar Motif
might have happened once more with
t'challa again realizing that this will
just start a cycle of violence mbaku
warns of wakanda and talukand evolving
into nations of Eternal War which I
think may have been a theme that was
apparent in the original version I do
think that by the sounds of it the basic
backbone of the film would have been the
same with the Charla questioning his
leadership which does get replaced by
shuri questioning her own skills and
abilities to hear the fact that she
couldn't make a herb is her basically
thinking that she led to his death and
no that's not the case I think this
Motif would have mirrored the failure
t'challa felt about his own kingdom
unfortunately we'll never know what the
original script would have played out
like due to the death of Chadwick
Boseman but I personally think that the
final result perfectly handles his
passing grief is a central theme to it
it drives the characters and their
actions in the movie though t'challa is
gone his presence is felt throughout and
we of course are no knowing that his
legacy carries on either way there's
lots to unpack from this and obviously
let me know your thoughts on the script
details and your general thoughts on the
movie too wearing a competition right
now giving away three copies of House of
the Dragon season 1 on the 15th of
December and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe and
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
pick the comments at random on the 15th
and the winners of the last one are on
the screen right now save that to you
then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out one
of our wakanda forever breakdowns linked
on screen right now there's lots of
things to talk about in the movie
especially that post credit scene so
definitely head over there right after
this without the way thanks for sticking
through the video I've been Paul and
I'll see you next time take care peace